here's what would happen if the world  lost oxygen for an hour with the oxygen  gone you'd struggle to catch your breath  and your heart would start beating in  overdrive you could expect excruciating  chest pains the combustion process in  vehicles wouldn't be possible with no  oxygen so any mode of transportation  that wasn't electric would automatically  fail planes would fall from the sky and  millions of cars would be left abandoned  oxygen acts as a special binding agent  so any Building made out of concrete  would collapse instantly our ozone layer  is made of oxygen atoms that have bonded  to create ozone so Earth's protection  against UV rays would completely  disappear the planet would begin to get  extremely hot on top of all that Earth's  crust would crumble until there's  nothing left as its 45 oxygen and just  like that the human race and any  evidence that it existed is gone because